hey youtubers its charlie this is gonna
be big legends of tomorrow update they
were doing up fronts for international
TV buyers and the actors revealed some
more details about the show it was
actually at the ctv up front and if
you're wondering about you know where
it's gonna air in the world it'll be
available all the places that the flash
and arrow are available it's been
selling really well internationally so
first wait a big detail season 1 is
gonna be 15 episodes long and there
probably will be a season 2 the CW
hasn't ordered a second season yet you
know usually they wait till after the
first couple of episodes to see how a
shows doing but it's being planned out
just like arrow in the flash are so
it'll keep going as long as they want it
to keep going it's going to start in
January whenever arrow and flash come
back now the official date isn't
confirmed but err on the flash come back
about the third week in January so
that's probably when it's gonna start I
know a lot of you are asking why is it
only 15 episodes that's a totally weird
number well I think there's a lot of
evidence in the way they pitched the
series Marc Guggenheim said that if the
flash is supposed to feel like a
one-hour movie each week Legends is
supposed to feel like a one-hour summer
blockbuster every week and it's really
hard to up the level of spectacle and
special effects every week if you have
to spread your budget across 23 episodes
but they've probably done is the same
thing that agent Carter did where you
reduce the number of episodes that you
produce but you get the same budget you
would for a full series a full series
order can be anything from like 18 to 24
episodes so the CW probably did is like
okay we'll give you the money for 23
episodes just like we would for any
other series like the flash or arrow you
know a similar budget you produce fewer
episodes and you get to spend way more
money on each episode just to make it
that much crazier looking that much more
bigger and badass it's just that
whenever agent Carter aired they
budgeted out you know around like 13
episodes like you would a limited series
they only produced eight so they got to
spend almost twice as much money for
each episode that doesn't mean that
legends is always gonna be 15 episodes
long but it'll always probably like a
slightly reduced run so they can spend a
little bit more money on each episode
and the really important thing to
remember is that 15 number because arrow
and the flash last year only aired 14
episodes in the back half so you see
where I'm going here you know they're
gonna be a lot of crossovers between all
three shows what they might do is the
same thing they did with the arrow and
the flash finale
this year where the characters cross
over and then like in the finale of the
second show everything gets resolved so
we might have some issue like in the
last episode of arrow that the people
help out with from the other shows then
that story kind of carries over into the
flash finale the week after that and
then the week after that and in like the
third week in legends of tomorrow
everything gets resolved
so you have a lot of overlapping stories
and there's a reason why each show
doesn't have their finale in the same
week speaking of which we have no idea
what day it's gonna air on you know
it'll probably air on a different day
from air on the flash just so they can
maximize crossover potential I'm
thinking it's either gonna be Monday or
it's gonna be like Thursday it all just
comes down to like what they want the
show to compete against the problem with
mondays are is that the CW is a big fan
of that
8 o'clock timeslot currently that's
where Supergirl is going to be airing on
CBS
so if legends of tomorrow were to air on
mondays at 8 p.m. it would be competing
with Supergirl and I don't think that
they want to do that if you haven't seen
any of my previous videos it's just the
same people that make arrow the flash
and legends of tomorrow also make
Supergirl so like they want them all to
do well Thursday and Friday are just
like the logical places to stick that
just because Sunday night is so
competitive with like Walking Dead and
way more popular shows Friday is kind of
like a graveyard of TV that's like where
you send a TV show when you want it to
die so I just I feel like Thursday is
the best option after that that way if
something happened on the flash on
Tuesday it could carry over into arrow
the next day and then the day after that
they could solve the problem so if they
wanted to they could tell like an entire
self-contained three-part story in a
single week that feels like a really
badass movie which is what they're kind
of trying to create they're trying to
create like a movie type universe on TV
I know that a lot of questions about
like the big crossovers because we had
flash vs. arrow and we have brave in the
bold
they're gonna keep doing that with air
on the flash but now that we have
legends they're probably gonna do like
one big flare o-type crossover and then
a couple more minor ones meaning that
you'll have an episode where everybody's
in like the pilot probably everybody's
gonna be in that first episode after
that though whenever characters cross
over it'll probably on their own so like
you'll have a flash episode of legends
of tomorrow then you'll have like an
arrow episode of legends of tomorrow for
the most part though Barry and Oliver
will stay
on their own shows just because legends
is going to revolve around its main
actors which is given like the white
canary the atom firestorm Victor Garber
the guy that plays Martin Stein actually
said a little bit about what's going on
with firestorm so he kind of confirmed
that firestorm would appear in the first
episode of the flash season 2 just is a
follow-up to like that big you know
universe altering time vortex and he and
Ronnie Raymond would appear in the first
episode of legends of tomorrow and then
they'd probably go their separate ways
he didn't say anything about Ronnie
Raymond dying but I know everyone's
wondering why Robbie Amell isn't on the
spin-off show and it's probably just
because his film career is taking off
and he has a bunch of conflicts
seriously since the Tomorrow People
ended he's been shooting a ton of movies
so he probably just wasn't able to sign
up for the full series so they had to
write a story around that to explain why
he wasn't around Marc Guggenheim did say
that they wouldn't put like one half of
firestorm on legends of tomorrow without
allowing him to do firestorm things so
even when Ronnie leaves Martin Stein
will still be doing firestorm stuff
meaning that we'll probably have to go
to jason rusch like i said that doesn't
confirm that Ronnie's gonna die or
anything but in the comics it's just
that jason rusch only became firestorm
when Ronnie died that was during the
identity crisis storyline that was
actually you know a long time ago
it seems like for now like the flare
overs you know legends arrow in the
flash are sticking with the paradigm
that firestorm requires two people to
operate one person to be the body and
one mind to drive the body DC changed
that a long time ago in the comics the
latest they made it so that Jason Rusch
and Ronnie Raymond can both be firestorm
on their own they they don't need Martin
Stein they even did like the
Transformers thing where like when
Ronnie and Jason both become firestorm
they can combine to form like a super
giant mega firestorm which is kind of
funny they are totally not gonna do that
on the TV show they're just way too
ridiculous the mystery characters that
could be jason rusch is the jay jackson
character that could be like like a
placeholder name just like they do with
ted kord earlier this year he ended up
being Ray Palmer instead the reasoning
behind turning Ted Kord into Ray Palmer
on arrow it was a little bit different
that was like a like a DC executive
decision they're just like we have other
plans for Ted Kord you can't use Blue
Beetle it's kind of a bummer because I
feel the way Brandon routs character
worked was designed for Ted Kord
it's just that that storyline you know
like the Felicity race storyline was was
meant to be a little bit lighter a
little bit more awkward that is Ted Kord
through and through Ray Palmer has a
little bit of a harder edge
Brandon Roth has done a great job of
making that character his own but I feel
like it's gonna take most of Legends out
tomorrow to develop him but just going
back to firestorm you know I just I feel
like the only reason they have for not
announcing who this mystery J Jackson
character is going to be like the comic
book character he's playing is that it
it's a big plot spoiler for firestorm
like the JJ and J Jackson is supposed to
be a reference to the RR of Ronnie
Raymond that's just a theory though and
remember even if it is Jason Rush and he
becomes part of firestorm it doesn't
mean that they have to kill off Ronnie
Raymond Robbie Amell is just like too
big of an actor for them to throw away
so they'll probably find a way for him
to come back in the future here's my big
question for you guys though do you feel
like J Jackson this J Jackson character
is really supposed to be jason rusch and
he'll become part of firestorm and a lot
of you are also asking about Arthur
Darvill rip hunter character I am gonna
do a separate bonus video for him but
there are a couple big storylines that
you can read to prepare there's this one
called time masters vanishing point it
came after Final Crisis whenever
Darkseid's Omega beam sent bet band back
in time rip hunter assembled the team to
time-travel to try and find him there's
also this other series just called time
masters it's from the early 90s the
really cool thing about rip hunter is
that he's Booster Gold son nicest
douchebag time traveler in the DC
universe a while ago in the comics they
they actually explained why Booster Gold
has to be such a douchebag it's really
just an act so that people don't know
what his true purpose is booster is like
the secret origin of the time masters IV
obviously time masters is rip hunter but
Booster Gold gives birth to rip hunter
who gives birth to the time masters so
Booster Gold himself very important in
the history of the universe as for the
big villain Vandal Savage I'm gonna do a
separate video for him real soon a real
good story for him to read is DC 1
million that's like a three-part story
so it's pretty small
there's DC Universe presents vol 2
Vandal Savage that's all about his
daughter it's like a very Hannibal
Lecter Silence of the Lambs type story
and then there's demon nights which is a
story set during medieval times in the
DC Universe yeah actually you know what
demon nights that
the best Vandal Savage story so just
start there I will talk more about some
of these stories in my Vandal Savage
video but my next video will probably
that rip hunter video so be sure to
subscribe to get that I'll try to post
that next week I feel like talking about
legends of tomorrow it's like a good
warm-up for Doctor Who which is actually
gonna start later this summer actually
most of you guys if you've never watched
Doctor Who before let me know just so I
can adjust my videos accordingly I'm not
really gonna do stuff for that - like
July or August so don't worry about that
yet but in case you guys didn't see in
my guardians 2 video that I did
yesterday
I'm doing a new weekly Marvel and DC
giveaway that's two different giveaways
every week and it'll start whenever I
post my Marvel and DC videos next week
you know whichever first ones are so
just be sure to check out any Marvel or
DC videos that I post next week for
details I am working on an arrow season
4 video that should post later tonight
but while you guys wait for that you can
click here to learn all about mirror
master coming to season 2 of the flash
and you can click here to learn about
some of my favorite Batman stories from
decade to decade Arkham Knight is like
right around the corner so thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight